No
right welcome everyone to this meeting
of cabinet a particular welcome to
Jeffrey Harris who's joined us as
portfolio holder for health well-being
and housing welcome Jackie apologies for
absence do we have any apologies yes
apologies to see from council organ yes
counselor organized not a funeral
disclosures or interest any disclosures
of interest no minutes confirm and
signed the minutes of the meeting held
on 2nd of July any issues on the minutes
in that case I will sign the minutes
after the meeting is there truth fair
record item for notice of motion loud
between the letter centre car park and
fisherman's car park councillor moss
Germany will see this is a fairly
straightforward motion regarding the man
between the fisherman's car parking and
the leisure centre car park it's a site
which is great year of growing very
scruffy frankly is not a credit to the
tang doesn't even say so this is a
request for a very clever look our
offices at the potential of bringing
this back into you more useful and
presentable state two points that would
make a chairman one is that what we're
looking at is the high level we're not
asking for a huge great in-depth report
it's however a report to see what the
possibilities may say and I think as far
as the officers are concerned we're
pushing it an open door because I
believe they've done some preparatory
work on this and from my conversations
within clearly there's always a question
of finance chairman and we have asked
here too
specifically to explore whether grants
are available on the landfill tax scheme
there's a lot of encouragement to use
used landfill tax money for
reinstatement of previous schemes so we
might get some money out of engine Thank
You Council Mars councillor pebble
attempt English this way yeah thank
thank thank you thank you and good
afternoon
councillor Morse and I in principle
that's all sounds really fine but I
think my only observation would be
that as an organization we have set
ourselves already a significant number
of projects and tasks that hat that we
have already prioritized in our tasks
that tie into our corporate strategy and
things that we want to develop to the
wider benefit of all residents and I
think my only concern in the short to
medium term is the bandwidth to do to
actually do this even at a high level
you talk about looking at you know the
landfill tax you can't really do a high
level assessment as to whether you can
assess grants in that way you've got to
do the work properly and whilst I don't
think for I wouldn't for a second be
suggesting that we we kicked this into
touch and ignore it entirely I think it
is a case at the moment I'm not
convinced we of the the bandwidth to
take this additional piece of work on
for the officers an employer would be
that we do keep this and put it on the
on the longer list and not to avoid it
completely but I think we just need to
compress revisit it maybe at the turn
you know into the new year
that would be I think if I can pick pick
this up because it's very interesting
that we have the looking
the land between the measure centre car
park and fisherman's car park
fisherman's car park in particular there
was something that came up that we did
explore with a nephew mutual that is not
going ahead but I think in particular
with the bandwidth issue particularly I
think in the light of all that is going
on and the wells will airfield one
having coming rather suddenly and it's
short notice in the over the next six
months personally I do not think we have
the bandwidth to cope with this when we
have everything else going on and the
other things I think are more
significant and more significance to
most of our population so my view would
be I think I would endorse what
councilor Pemberton says we are aware of
this it will not go away completely but
in the short I think this is not
something we would wish to pursue so my
recommendation would be that at this
point in time we dismiss this notice of
motion is everyone happy with that
absolutely comfortable and just to make
it clear where we're making you know
we're deferring this we're not just you
know we're not dismissing it completely
it's just let's do things well and and
then move on to the next one you're
given three options on the report is how
you wish to deal with the item assume
you're selecting B to defer
consideration of the report until the
next available meeting but in this
regard you suggest in early in 2019
instead of the next available
thank you for summarizing that
brilliantly mr. Buckland everyone happy
with that
he agreed good so item five and as
Chancellor Harris has only just joined
cabinet I think it will be wrong over
from fair to have her present this paper
no I'm very kind inconsiderate but it
won't last you will say that when we
have this paper presented at the
Cavanaugh pre meet which is now a week
before cabinet we went through this
paper and we were I think it would be
fair to say not happy with it we thought
there was an awful lot of information
missing in some cases the information
that was provided kind of led us to some
conclusions that turned out to be
erroneous for example number three to
where it actually says current spending
was three hundred and two thousand gross
for the year today that meant the
spending in the year of that run rate
would have been 1.1 million so we sought
clarification and as a result of that
you have the supplementary paper in
front of you which I think addresses all
the issues that were raised and at the
moment you can actually say that the
savings per year if we do this will be
sixty thousand seven hundred and seventy
two and it also enables the enables us
to provide a much better service to the
homeless and probably will avoid any
chance of a judicial review
some of the people who may stay longer
in bed and breakfast so we can see the
recommendations on the original paper at
page 11 I would however say that I think
we should add a recommendation 5 and
that is that there's a report on
performance to cabinet every six months
so we can actually check exactly how
well this is performing any comments or
any description from cabinet in that
case can I have support for all the
recommendations including recommendation
now 5 report on performance to cabinet
every six months the recommendations are
on page 11 in favor thank you so we now
move on to item 6 which is councilor
Pemberton and it's the Eddington and
full ready Neighborhood Development Plan
proceed to referendum Chancellor
Pemberton Thank You leader the etting
tanam fall ready neighborhood
development plan is now quite a
significant way down the track in terms
of its development there's been a lot of
good work done by the the neighborhood
development plan team across in
Eddington and in full ready and by our
officers and we've reached the stage
where the examiner has provided comments
in terms of pros and modifications which
are being in which have been added and
if you if you take a look at appendix
one you can see there's a track change
document they're showing all the
modifications and in essence this is now
ready to go out to its referendum stage
and really seeking recommend the
recommendation that the medic the
modifications that are set out in
Appendix 1 are received and adores
and that the the etting t'en an and full
ready Neighborhood Development Plan B
endorsed and it should now be in a
position to proceed to its referendum
stage and clearly the sooner that can be
done the sooner that this piece of work
and then go into the library of plans
that we can use as far as development
control planning a concern so I would be
looking for support for the
recommendations as set out on page 15
any discussion any questions in that
case all those in favor of the
recommendations on page 55 that's a
great unanimously
so now item 8 which I believe is you
once again
Burton thank you thank you leader and in
and in the in the cause of brevity I do
is that I would almost just replace with
Wells Ben and Walton Neighborhood
Development Plan first of all you know
we should record the work that has been
done to get us to this point but again
we're at the examiner's modifications
and comment stage and at the point where
we can be looking for the plan to go out
to referendum and I do see councillor
Perry wishing to to make some comments
so at that point I think I'll just hold
fire I'm sorry councillor Perry Thank
You leader and members of the cabinet
since Wells fallen Walton Parish Council
applied for in the entire parish area to
be designated as a neighbourhood plan
area back it was nearly four years ago
to the data actually August 2004 teen
there's been a phenomenal amount of work
that's been undertaken by the chairman
of the wells born and Walton
neighborhood plan and its committee over
the last four years of which I'm very
proud and pleased to have been part of a
huge amount of consultation has taken
part since since 2014 such as the
interest I think it's
a really interesting point over a
thousand residents took part in the
questionnaire survey now that has to be
one of the highest responses back to any
neighborhood plan that has come before
the cabinet and the council over a
thousand local residents actually
completed and returned the comprehensive
questionnaire survey and as someone who
actually completed the analysis I can
tell you it was quite an extensive
project there have been many challenges
which have had to be overcome and our
facts are particularly extended to both
nath Matthew Neal and John Kerr furred I
see sitting in the bank for their
diligence advice and support and
therefore ask that the cabinet look very
favorably on endorsing the world's
warming little neighborhood development
plan as modified so that we can proceed
to referendum on Thursday the 11th of
October thank you thank thank you leader
councillor Perry I couldn't have put it
better myself unfortunately though I do
recall I think you may have come a very
very close second to two biddeford in
that one but very very good performance
overall and yes I think will echo the
endorsement and the request by the the
ward member there councillor kettle you
when you approve the previous motion you
said promotion on page 55 which is of
course the world's born on Walton you
should have approved previously the
motion on page 15 I'll leave it to mr.
Grafton to subtract the complexities of
that particular one Thank You mr.
Grafton what do I do now
that's a good one and I think we were
all clear well I was certainly clear at
the time what we were approving I do
take your point but I think it's clear
that the minutes will will show that the
approval
earlier on related to the
recommendations on page 15 Thank You
counselor careful for that leader just
just to afford some further level of
comfort to the Chairman I can assure you
that so we have in the room a highly
professional webcast operator who will
have recorded everything and we will be
able to be absolutely certain for for
your benefit and for the monitoring
officers benefit for ourselves and
anybody watching that we were clear on
what we were voting on councillor Harris
you want house sorry you have to to
speak Morris I just wanted to make a
small comment if I can in conjunction
with this plan it's really nice to see
the Stratford District Council
supporting the airfield under a s9 and
the other thing that I picked up in the
report that was born airfield status as
a local heritage asset has been
confirmed and I think that recognizes
the contribution that was made by many
of the Canadian services airmen who lost
their lives at wellsworth during the
Second World War and I think it's a
fitting tribute that it's now being
considered as a local heritage asset
thank you for that counselor house
points are noted and do note everything
you said councillor Perry I do fully
appreciate the immense amount of work
that goes into these neighborhood plans
and I think wells born and Walton abate
to be commended on the fact of a
thousand residents responded to the
questionnaire that is a very very
significant rate of response so with
that I will now try and get it right and
say that the recommendations on page 55
our cabinet in agreement with them
agreed thank you for that so now we move
on to item 8 starting on page 95 which
is a shots will perish plan and once
councillor Pemberton it's you Thank You
leader we've now got to the point with
the shots well parish plan that it is it
is complete it's an excellent piece of
work conducted by the parish plan team
and supported by Matthew Neill and so
John if you could pass on my thanks to
Matthew for his work on this and this
this document is now in a position where
we can adopt it as a material
consideration in accordance with the
core strategy a point was raised fairly
at a fairly advanced stage in the
preparation of the plan around housing
the survey and what and really just
fought for explanation the plan is in
conformity the plan is a good plan and
so it was felt by all that's actually
delaying the plan to conduct a housing
needs survey the benefits of so doing
would be outweighed by the disadvantages
of not having the parish plan as part of
the the local source information for the
core strategy but you will note that
under recommendation 2 we are asking the
shots well parish council to give
consideration to producing a new housing
needs survey and that you know clearly
we can provide some support there as and
as and when that that decision comes to
fruition and I do I see counselor
Fielding wishing to to come and make a
comment on all there at that point to
see stop councillor fielding thank you I
wasn't Institute
neither one thanks him Tim brooke-taylor
and all others that have been involved
in this I have to thank everyone for
approving it if you approve it so Thank
You councillor fielding so without
further ado the recommendations on page
95 the shots will perish plan be adopted
as a material consideration etc is
everyone happy with those
recommendations three and I think for
all three of the parish plans that have
come forward as is our custom we should
actually express our thanks to the
parishes for all the hard work that has
gone into these because we all know how
significant the amount of work is so if
that could be recorded please okay
where we are now now on item 9 which is
the draft reserve strategy as identified
in Appendix 1 we approved as councilor
organ is not present today has given her
apologies and he's at a funeral I think
I will take this paper it was
recommended by the Pia challenge team
that the council considers the
introduction of a reserve strategy we
have looked at the level the minimum
level of reserves that has been needed
and that is outlined in Appendix 1 so
the level of reserves has actually
increased to 2.5 million I would also
draw people's attention to on page 143
of Appendix 1 they increasing financial
risks and there is no doubt about it
financial risks are I think increasing
into the future if one actually looks at
the context of the UK there is no doubt
about that the pressures on public
spending in taxation are very
significant and the OB are continually
forecasts that the current position is
going into the future unsustainable
nevertheless what we have done now is I
think taken a very prudent view we've
increased the general levels of reserve
to 2.5 billion I would also point out
that on page 145 we adopt a strategy to
utilize our reserves more effectively in
initiatives which either provide an
ongoing income stream or that result in
a reduction of ongoing costs and I think
the earlier paper today does indicate we
are using some of those for reduction in
ongoing costs and we will consider more
of those initiatives in the next version
of the medium term financial plan so
without further ado the recommendation
on page 139 that the draft reserve
strategy identified at Appendix 1 be
approved any comments any questions all
those in favor agree thank you ladies
and gentlemen so moving on to item 10
which is the capital budget monitoring
period 1 2 3 20 18 to 19 and this is
usually a fairly routine report in the
wise words of count
however just confer with customers you
talk about that has an infrastructure
fund okay of course that process hasn't
concluded chairman in relation to the
consideration Lisa there has an
investment fund for funding process we
have formal notification that we've
passed the first hurdle in relation to
the for funding bid to support the
south-western relief road and we're
working with Holmes England now in
working through the additional evidence
and information they need to take that
for to the next stage so it doesn't
appear in your papers today because it's
not my actually secured the marginal
viability fund to be absolutely fair I
think mr. Webb might be able to comment
further on that particular yeah thank
you came and yeah the - if David said
there are two types of money that I can
so bid for that has in infrastructure
fund marginal funding which is on sites
redevelopment or remediation that was
thirteen point four million so the 55 is
not massively accurate it's 53
[Music]
but the what's happened with the
thirteen point four million is that the
both the council and the developer I've
met with represented some times England
and we provided information to them the
process for agreeing marginal funding is
a lot shorter than the forward funding
bid so we would expect that we will get
notification that we have formally got
that money probably in the next few
months seven three year I think that the
total amounts of money it was fifty
three point four million and not fifty
five million
thank thank you leader I think if we can
cut to the chase and sort of reassure
councillor Moss because the underlying
question is around the suggestion that
this this forward funding is at risk and
there is no suggestion whatsoever and no
evidence whatsoever suggest that either
of these pots of money are in any way
shape or form at risk by virtue of any
so-called failings on behalf of the
administration of this council as David
Buckland has indicated to you we are
part way through a process and we have
cleared the hurdles of the process that
we are we've been asked to clear so far
and certainly the 40 million pounds
which is part of the wmca bid of circa
215 million is a piece of ongoing work
so just to reassure councillor Morse
don't worry
we haven't messed it up I think I would
just say that councillor Richards may
have been a little premature in his play
I think what I would also say is that
undertaking these bids is never a
one-man band
it is nearly always a team effort that
an awful lot of the people around this
table have been involved in that so I
think they can take some credit in fact
very considerable credit for the work
done in at getting that money allocated
although it is not yet finalized so with
that can I turn to the recommendation on
page one four nine councillor Morse are
you happy
councillor Morse I can assure you that
cabinet and council will get fully will
be kept fully up-to-date on progress it
is in everyone's interest that we are
totally and utterly transparent on these
things so with that without further adue
recommendation on page 149 you can read
it there is everybody happy with that
recommendation all agreed thank you
so moving on to item where is it item 11
page 161 revenue budget monitoring again
counting organ is has given her
apologies I would just reiterate her
time-honored phrase it is what it is it
is a federal report are there any
questions or any issues on the report in
that case turning to the recommendations
on page 161 is everyone happy with the
recommendations on page 161 agree in
that case I have agreement on those so
if we tell them now to the agenda we
have unblocked items which are item 12
destructed up on Aven markets for them
everyone happy with that
agreed I have no urgent business
mr. Webb another to business chairman in
that case
your correction is noted counselor
failing and with that can I declare the
meeting closed